[Music]
as for how mary's halftime co-headliner
eminem is feeling
i'm beginning to feel like a rap gun i'm
gonna tell you it's nerve-racking like
this is like
this to me it's like there's nothing
more final
than live tv he's nervous but on the
surface he looks calm and ready
he's there forever
what he was nervous about is that it's
live you know and he's been rapping for
20-plus years and he you can forget
lyrics when you've been rapping that
long sirius xm sway calloway with et
today even with 10 number one albums and
220 million records sold worldwide it's
still m's first time at halftime and
he's blown away by dr dre's ambitious
vision i was thinking like yeah that's
don't fit all of us are gonna rap but i
didn't expect it to be like the
production to be like this he said it's
like nothing you ever seen before will
there be surprise guests absolutely
there are surprise guests and what was
your reaction when you found out who
they were damn okay his lips are sealed
but did national anthem performer mickey
guyton let a secret slip is there anyone
in particular that you're excited to see
on that stage oh my god i heard i have
50 cents
from dre and eminem's collaborator
popping up to mary jays anderson pock
just wow he's just been someone that i
fell in love with
and fans aren't putting this reunion
rumor on ice nwa might be getting back
together
[Music]
if it happens it would be nwa's first
reunion since 2016. and this super bowl
star connected rapper could bring more
girl power to halftime has anybody
reached out what i don't know what you
want me to say like a surprise it's
supposed to be a surprise
you